The answer is 184, you lose more than a quarter of all output levels when you
gamma correct an 8 bit image. Doing so can lead to what's called banding.
Especially with the lower values where you can see the different levels due to
the gaps. Here's one solution; it uses the observation that each channel
computed will be either a new one, in which case you want to add it to a count.
Or it's a previous one that you've already seen. That bit of code was from
Patrick Cozzi, and frankly, it was better than mine. Patrick, Mauricio, and
later on Branislav did massive amounts of work on this course's material.
Thanks so much, guys. This course is at least twice as good as it would have
been without their help.